okay let's get into audience questions
for the week some uh some good ones i
must say i'm impressed with the audience
first question david what happens to
drug
trafficking uh and the illegal drug
trade if all
drugs are decriminalized or legalized
so these are really two questions what
happens to drug trafficking
with decriminalization is very different
than what happens to drug trafficking
with legalization so
if we just see decriminalization of
drugs
in terms of possession you're not going
to see a drastic change to trafficking
in that case
the cartels won't really need to change
anything in order to continue being
profitable
operationally i don't think that they
would see any anything major
change but you would start to maybe see
some changes when it comes to american
institutions
maybe at the prison level you would see
some differences although i don't think
they would be as big
as some people think i'm going to get
back to that um
you would probably see more
people suffering from addiction
willing to go and seek treatment
because of this word decriminalization
it's no longer a
criminal thing but i think for the most
part
from a dealer's standpoint from a cartel
standpoint
from a gang standpoint and we know about
the overlap between drugs drugs and
gangs
you would see operating you would see
them operating basically the same way
they do
um although maybe they would
shift a little bit to areas where
you could leverage something that is
still
completely criminal rather than
decriminalized but still not
really okay um and remember that
when we talk about decriminalization and
legalization
were talking about possession for use
and the idea of um
when even in cases of legalization you
still need to be licensed i mean look at
cigarettes as an example cigarettes
which are
legal you still see a black market for
cigarettes
and you still see people trying to pay
less for them
by going obtaining them in ways other
than the way that
the government has established through
regulation should be done
uh now if you actually saw legalization
um i think that that would take a big
bite out of the black market
i think you would see if there was
really full legalization
where state government or federal
government or both says as has been done
with cannabis in a lot of places already
this is now legal as long as you're
licensed to produce and sell it
there are some limits in terms of how
much any individual can have or grow
and you need to be 21 and you need to be
paying taxes in this way and that type
of thing
you would still have a black market
which would likely be cheaper and you
still
see that but it might actually impact
the level of violence to some degree you
i think that you would actually see a
decrease in the amount of violence
but it would be less violence related to
the production and distribution of that
substance
you would still have gangs and cartels
my expectation would be
if you legalize more and more drugs
you'd see gangs and cartels
go in the direction of human trafficking
organ trafficking extortion kidnapping
protection and the sort of example or
model for that
is look at the united states during
alcohol prohibition in the early 20th
century
um it created a different
uh uh criminal world and then
when it was re-legalized it's not like
criminality went away
it was a switch we've seen uh mafias
switch from uh and to you know from
alcohol
to gambling or prostitution or whatever
the case may be
so then let's talk about the prison
thing with decriminalization
of personal use amounts alone
i actually am not sure that american
prison populations would dramatically
decrease and what i mean by that is the
following
yes uh some people do end up in prison
simply for possession of personal use
uh drugs for the most part like
overwhelmingly
people that are imprisoned for drugs are
in prison
because they either were involved in
uh the trade and had amounts that are
far bigger
than what would be decriminalized or
legalized
and what we're seeing already at the
state level bears this out
or it's drugs connected to other crimes
as well
so i think if you were to legalize
decriminalize
and say everybody in prison simply for
a personal possession drug charge
is being let out the u.s would still be
very very high in terms of per capita
incarceration globally
and i don't know that simply
decriminalizing or legalizing personal
use amounts
is actually going to be the big
improvement from a criminal justice
standpoint as some people believe that
it's going to be those are the numbers i
found
if you disagree let me know one of our
sponsors is steady md
primary care the easier and more
affordable way to do primary care and
they're giving you
50 off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on
your doctor will be available to you by
text phone and video chat
it's not some random doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz and see which doctor is a
perfect fit for you
you'll get 50 off your first month when
you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video